[Musik]
der schweizer filmpreis die große gala
mit glaubens und glamour sie war geplant
für freitag und findet wie so vieles
zurzeit nicht statt
dafür gibt es am nächsten freitagabend
unsere spezialsendung in drei
landessprachen zum schweizer filmpreis
zu sehen auf sf2 und bereits morgen
verkündet das bundesamt für kultur wer
die diesjährigen gewinnerinnen und
gewinner sind das heißt heute können wir
hier in dieser kritiker runde mit dennis
buchmesse goldberg und seine petersen
noch leidenschaftlich über die
nominierten spielfilm über die
nominierten filme diskutieren und auch
lustvoll spekulieren wer gewinnen wird
oder wer gewinnen könnte ja und diese
fünf filme finden sind nominiert in der
sparte beste schweizer spielen als in
berlin die mauer fiel war in der schweiz
noch immer alles beim alten
die komödie zur fischen affäre moskau
einfach
[Musik]
jagd nach so versieben kräften im
zürcher schauspielhaus iraker im
londoner exil bagdad in my shadow wenn
die vergangenheit die zukunft bestimmt
[Musik]
wenn alles zerfällt migliori sohn
familientragödie in der sommerhitze
unheimlicher urknall mysteriöses drama
um heranwachsende in genf
erfolgreiche zivilisationskritik bruno
manser die stimme des regenwaldes
die bildgewaltige lebensgeschichte des
schweizer umweltaktivisten dass also die
fünf nominierten spielfilme für den
schweizer filmpreis 20 20 den ist bucher
sie sind filmkritikerin bei der nzz am
sonntag auch präsidentin des vereins der
schweizer film kritikerinnen und
kritiker welche von diesen fünf
nominierten spielfilm ist mit ihr
favorit ich schwanke doch ich kann mich
nicht ganz entscheiden zwischen leeb
artikel migliori so also den beiden
russen genau und herz tendenz
wahrscheinlich lebt artikel ja ja eine
ansage partikels gold bei diesen
filmhistorikerin was denken sie jetzt
die akademie entscheidet ja
schlussendlich wäre aus diesen fünf den
schweizer filmpreis gewinnt als bester
schweizer spiele finden was denken sie
wer wird das rennen machen was
historisch gesehen hat der film von der
westschweizerin vielleicht die besten
chancen weil es das immer wieder
es kommt immer wieder vor dass während
das wäre mit larissa
also das ist mal ihr tipp oder ihre
wahrnehmung was es sein können
verdientesten sie berichten fürs
schweizer fernsehen immer wieder über
schweizer filme jetzt ist ja ein film
nicht unter den nominierten die man
erwartet hätte platzspitz baby
inzwischen fast 300.000 eintritte
gemacht einer der erfolgreichsten filme
es definitiv von diesem jahr
da gibt es eine kurze erklärung dazu
warum der nicht dabei ist unter diesen
nominierten ja wurde nicht eingereicht
und dahinter steckt ein sehr
kalkulierter entscheid vom produzenten
von peter reichenbach vom c films der
hat sich gesagt ja also fürs marketing
bringt uns das nicht viel
und nächstes jahr kann man ihn ja auch
noch einreichen und jetzt hat eigentlich
die perfekte ausgangslage weil jeder
spricht über den großen
abwesenden wir hier jetzt auf wir wissen
eigentlich alle
es wäre wahrscheinlich der favorit
gewesen hätte gute chancen gehabt da
nicken alle gut also das ist die
erklärung platzspitz baby nicht dabei
und wir sprechen jetzt auch über die
nominierten filme und über zwei
nominierte filme wollen wir etwas
ausführlicher diskutieren das eine ist
die komödie moskau einfach von micha
lewinsky das andere ist wie midori
soeben das flimmern am horizont von
regisseurin delfin risse der vielen der
lief sehr erfolgreich in der romandie
über 10.000 eintritt theater gemacht und
er hat von allen filmen die nominiert
sind für den schweizer filmpreis auch am
meisten nominationen gekommen nämlich 4
warum geht's in le mans der lori song
wir schauen uns würde ich mal sagen eine
schlüsselszene an es ist der hitze
sommer 1976 alles klärt und die
emotionen kochen hoch
am 1
[Musik]
der 13-jährige günstigen bedeutet diese
sommer nicht nur das ende seiner
kindheit sondern erlernt auch ganz neue
saiten seiner mutter kennen familie
deloris und das ist der zweite spielfilm
der regisseurin delfin mehr risse dennis
fokussierung gesagt aus gast im kino
kaum waren sie froh dass es kalt war
draußen also das heißt man man man fühlt
diesen film ja sehr
ich würde dann nicht im sommer sehen
wollen ich habe nicht gern hitze und
wenn man schon im kino also ich kann
nicht mehr
und dann braucht es auch noch so heiß
das wäre dann wirklich zu viel gewesen
und dass die bilder die sie die sie
bringt die atmosphäre dieses wirklich
dieses flimmern und in der luft das ist
so gut gemacht dass man tatsächlich zu
schwitzen anfängt die die hitze
eigentlich fast aus heimliche
hauptdarstellerinnen ja irgendwie schon
man hat irgendwie alle sind überhitzt
und dann auch getrieben also die triebe
die brodeln hoch und das ist wunderbar
die filmt auch von christof bock garen
im bayrischen kameramann wie er das
flimmern so eingefangen hat sehr schön
wir haben es ist ja nicht nur die hitze
die die gefühle ich finde es ist auch
der tod die hitze bringt achten tot was
man halt so diese diesen widerspruch
dann plötzlich zwischen eben diese die
die erotik für die mutter und der tod
wird eigentlich tun haben könnte ja
sogar sagen also die tiere sterben dann
auch menschen selbst einmal gesagt dass
menschen sterben werden wenn es so
weitergeht man könnte den film wir auch
als einen film über die erderwärmung
lesen lang vor den klima protesten weil
er spielt der 19 76 öffentlich geworden
nicht nur dass man die hitze spürte ich
hatte das gefühl man riecht auch ja das
was stattfindet und vor allem auch die
vielen toten
wie viele hühner danach noch gestorben
sind an der hitze und man merkt man
sieht ihm im gesicht wie wie extrem das
stinkt in muss und das spürt man auch es
ist ein sehr sehr sinnlich auf
ich habe mich die ganze zeit beim
schauen gefragt wo gibt es in der
schweiz diese landschaften und habe
nachher im abspann herausgefunden dass
die in mazedonien haben zum teil auch in
belgien aber hauptsächlich in mazedonien
das so man
man kann diese
den wiesen leider nicht hier in der
schweiz finden jetzt eben man spürt also
offensichtlich da ist ganz viel
atmosphärisches ganz viel in den bildern
jetzt ist der film jahr eine literatur
verfügung
das basiert auf dem flimmern am horizont
das buch das ist von roland putin und
essig und die koffer heißt eigentlich
oder bütikofer heißt eigentlich fragte
ein schweizer buchpreis 2014 gewonnen
ich glaube ich brauche sie hatten lange
zeit nicht das gefühl das ist eine
literaturverfilmung ja ich hab's gar
nicht gewusst ich bin mal wieder
ahnungslose ins kino gelaufen und ich
habe einen kollegen getroffen zufällig
und wir haben uns nachher über den film
unterhalten und sie hat mir gesagt dass
es eine literaturverfilmung sei und ich
kann es nicht glauben weil sonst
literaturverfilmungen immer so von von
den worten abhängen dass es gibt
meistens dann erzählt figur was ich
nicht sehr mag und man hat das gefühl
man der film versucht das buch zu
imitieren und lehre macht etwas eigenes
daraus und sie übersetzt die atmosphäre
des buches ich habe es nicht gelesen
aber ich nehme an in einen film gemacht
sie macht etwas cineastisches daraus das
was ich schön kennt das buch auch nicht
aber für mich war klar dass eine
verfilmung ist ich habe es wie gespielt
und nicht dass ich finde auch gut wieder
nicht sagt dass es nicht diese off
stimme mit der materie kommentare das
ist mein kapitulieren eigentlichen bei
den verfilmungen aber auch dramaturgisch
gibt es einiges wie die figuren
eingeführt werden und wie die dm die
wendepunkte kommen in der geschichte es
wird nicht immer alles so begründet ich
denke sie haben das einfach aus der
romanvorlage übernommen weil man es
versteht wie viel zum film auch so sein
und haben sich ein bisschen zu wenig
mühe gegeben dass er auch in der firma
erzählung zu begründen einzubetten und
das ist für mich ein bisschen eine
schwäche des films was ich finde ihn
ohnehin sehr gelungen aber dramaturgisch
hat er für mich ein paar schwachpunkte
ich denke das liegt an dem ich möchte
noch etwas zur geschichte sagen also ich
habe auch das gefühl die regisseurin hat
sich den film zu eigen gemacht aber sie
hat sich eben wie ich gelesen habe auch
sehr in dem film erkannt
das ist eigentlich ihre geschichte aus
dem buch erkannte neben buch erkannt
richtig entschuldigen habe zu ihm gesagt
nämlich
hat auch sich in eine frau verliebt und
dann den vater des gemeinsamen sohns
verlassen und der mutter absolut ja und
ich finde man spürt dass das das ist das
eine sehr persönliche geschichte ja und
wenn man den ersten film kennt papi lauf
da merkt man das sind auch so ein
bisschen grundthemen so teenager problem
lesbische liebe das kommt immer wieder
vorbei
jetzt bin ich da so ein konsens also man
ist mit dem film sehr einverstanden aber
margot weg sie haben im vorgespräch
gesagt sie finde es ein typischer
autorinnen schweizer autorin sagt nein
ist nein das war mehr eine feststellung
das ist einfach der film hat überhaupt
nicht für mich die absicht ein
unterhaltungsfilm zu sein
das geht sehr um das emotionale das
psychologische porträt von einer familie
eben jetzt von dieser mutter auch von
dem julien der buchvorlage die
hauptfigur der film macht die mutter wie
seiner zweiten hauptfigur und es ist ein
film wo sehr viel gelitten wird wo dem
publikum keinen gefallen getan wird und
darum habe ich gesagt das sei in dieser
kategorie alten finden also nicht auch
nicht der beste comedy-sendung sommers
grund haben sie sich über die schweizer
ton firma lustig gemacht und die
entwicklung der witz und dass die firma
machen für machen die sich ums publikum
foutieren und enorme geschichten
erzählen wollen
und sie haben dass er ein bisschen
negativ besetzt für mich ist es nicht
unbedingt negativ besetzt aber es ist
keine leichte kost dieser führe ich
finde hingegen sehr schön dass die
geschichte mit der
gleichgeschlechtlichen liebe auch sehr
unaufgeregt und souverän erzielt wird
und das nicht sagen
das ist wie selbstverständlich auch
daherkommt er merkt man wie das kino
erfolg und das szene die wir gesehen
haben
man kann ja gar nicht entscheiden ob der
junge sich jetzt drüber aufregt ob die
frau die mutter mit einer anderen frau
genutzt oder ob es der betrug ist an der
familie
in den so stört es wird bis zum schluss
nicht aufgelöst oder ob jetzt auch
erotisch findet und mit sich selber
bringt der film beginnt mit einer szene
von herrsching klammheimlich aus dem
chaos ist ja auch er ist ja in der
pubertät da sehr leger seine vielleicht
kurz noch zurück brüche also das ist ein
15 jähriger walliser junge der seine
erste rolle spielt wurde auch gleich
nominiert für den schweizer filmpreis
hat also auch chancen zu gewinnen
das spürt man auch das leere sie ja
selber die deutsche syrien
schauspielerin war würde ich sagen oder
wie sie den für sie kommt aus dem
theater oder sie kann mit
schauspielführung kann sich schon was
anfangen mich erinnert dieser junge auch
so sehr an kacey mottet klein
also ich hab da so viele echos gehabt
aber erst am 18
von ursula meier vor allem laufen kommt
mir da einen sinn haben ihn auf der
leinwand erwachsenen sehen ja genau und
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass hier
etwas ähnliches passiert oder ich würde
es mir wünschen weil man kann sich nicht
satt sehen an dem gesicht ja möchte nur
kurz gearbeitet zwei frauen loben die
laetitia casta die man früher als
supermodel gekannt hat sie hat dann auch
als quereinsteigerin mit firmen bedienen
begonnen sie waren asterix und einer
größeren französischen kisten wie sie
kann sie als eine gute schauspielerin
sieht man gut spielen und obwohl der
film sie in dieser sehr hässliche mode
der damaligen zeit steckt trotzdem sehr
schön und strahlend und stimmungsmusik
rehmann vielleicht sie ist einfach so
zwischendurch sie ist einfach ein
phänomen gut aus ich spüre da einen
gewissen konsens mann ist begeistert
oder zufrieden oder findet aus einen
tollen film für musik und wird auch der
in der möglicherweise gewinnen wird was
einmal schaut genau ich denke wir kommen
zum zweiten der möglicherweise etwas
mehr kontroverse auslösen wirkte zweite
film den wir uns genau anschauen ist
moskau einfach von micha lewinsky
der film der spielzeit der fische affäre
also vor 30 jahren hunderttausende
wurden damals in der schweiz von der
geheim
polizei überwacht welches für micha
lewinsky verpackt jetzt dieses stück
schweizer geschichte in eine komödie ein
braver biedere polizist bekommt von
seinem vorgesetzten eine neue identität
verpasst und so als spitzel im super
sind im schauspielhaus herumschnüffeln
[Musik]
stelle genauso einlässt
franz hohler komplett in die hose machen
[Musik]
hast du die siko ihr eleganter wasser
merkel vernichten was mache ich meinen
flug ich kann sie sitz in groß sie sind
blitzgescheit
sie sind wiederum bundes sie sind
komplett umschwung aus sie erinnert
sagte ackermann
vicente geboren insider
[Musik]
die brummt muss ich habe jetzt gerade
darüber diskutiert ja aus dem polizisten
respektive ja aus dem weg zur schule
wird also der spitzel wolle hubacher in
willkommen es kam einfach
zudem bieten sie fingen diese komödie
dieser humor funktioniert sehr gut
ich finde meint müller und philippe
graber funktionieren so als schweizer
super bünzli allah die schweizermacher
und ich finde jedes mal wenn eine
komödie funktioniert dann bin ich schon
sehr zufrieden
und das tut sie das buch am anfang tut
sieht also ich glaube ich habe so die
ersten vielleicht 20 minuten war ich
dabei ich habe mich amüsiert es gab ein
paar gute pointen und die immer wenn man
die beiden zusammen sieht ja dann ist es
wirklich gut aber dann mit der zeit
fällt der vielen total in sich zusammen
fertig und es kommen nur noch es kommt
ein inszenatorische klischee nach dem
anderen zum zug und irgendwann habe ich
nur noch darauf gewartet dass es so
ausgeht wie ich erwarte dass es ausgeht
da ich das war dann die enttäuschung ich
fand ihn keine sekunde lang lustig ja
ich bin erst spannend das dass du das
comedy-duo rauskommen nein also
vielleicht bin ich nicht das tier
publikum für den film ich bin nicht hier
aufgewachsen sind wie man hört aber ich
habe mich auch für historisch mit dieser
zeit sehr auseinander gesetzen überhaupt
historisch und ich finde es
bemerkenswert dass ein film so
abschätzig mit seinem eigenen thema
umgeht für mich ist das nicht wirklich
ein lustig machen oder den im
satirischen oder aus als überzeugende
parodie oder als bissiger politsatire
oder sogar als also irgendwie ja
schenkel kopf kam also für mich hat er
überhaupt nicht funktioniert und die
ganze historische anlehnung ist für mich
eine verpasste chance sehr verspielt und
die die handlung 31 das ist wieder
einmal eine geschichte wo ein
tollpatschiger und überhaupt nicht
attraktiver junger mann sich in eine
frau verliebt
die ein bisschen zu krise ist in den
schauspielern und an diesem fall eine
schauspielerin aber ich werde jetzt von
diesem muster oder der manic pixi
dreamgirl oder dieser mann der diese
wahnsinns frau trifft und es ist am
schluss egal was ihr passiert hauptsache
er wächst in seiner entwicklung als man
das ist einfach ein schema xy aus dem
hollywoodfilm capital hat das sehr oft
erfolgreich verfilmt und für mich ist es
im prinzip das sehr vorhersehbaren und
dann mit diesen ganzen fischen fähre die
dann eigentlich so eine brisanz gehabt
hätte wird es einfach wie nur für die
situation rechnung ist sprechen wir mal
darüber also wie das fischen milieu
diese zeit 89 aus mauer fallen usw
das waren ja alle diese themen das
möchte ich auch noch anfügen also ich
stimme euch bei also die kritikpunkte
sie sind richtig getroffen aber ich bin
eben als komödie funktioniert das
funktioniert nicht das satire aber dass
wir das gar nicht sein
und es funktioniert leider auch nicht
als historische aufarbeitung ich habe
auch geschichte studiert habe auch die
zeit miterlebt da wird alles
verniedlicht und verharmlost also auf
dieser ebene funktioniert überhaupt
nicht auch die liebesgeschichte
funktioniert nicht aber dass man hat das
gefühl die vision affäre sei ein vorwand
für den film so ein verkaufsargument die
leute erinnern sich daran ein bisschen
wie bei platzspitz was es aber umsetzt
das ist eine zeit die irgendwie bewegend
war wo alle erinnerungen dran haben aber
dann passiert nichts damit dass es ist
einfach so ein
die bühne mit so ein paar beamten und
ein paar aktenschränken und aber was
darin gelagert wird
das spielt gar keine rolle und das ist
eigentlich dass das skandalöse und gibt
was damals geschehen ist passiert heute
wieder bloß machen wir alle ganz schön
freiwillig mit und niemand stört sich
dann am ende haben sie die immer machen
ja so die eine einstellung mit der
überwachungskamera soll wahrscheinlich
so den bogen zur gegenwart schlagen
aber da würde so viel drin liegen in
diesem thema der überwachung also könnte
darf eben auch etwas funktionieren also
der gerade jetzt für für sage ich mal
für jüngere generationen dir diese
fische affäre nicht mehr selber oder
nicht man selber erlebt haben dass sie
was erfahren über die geschichte und
gleichzeitig über ihren
ein haushalt mit den daten oder
freigeben von daten diskutieren oder
funktioniert da was nein es ist
historisch ist das fahrlässig was da
passiert es wäre besser die jungen
menschen würden das gar nicht
mitbekommen weil es besser man weiß gar
nichts als derzeit als dass man die
historische lektion durch diesen firmen
mitbekommt und es wird alles so
verharmlost und verniedlicht und der
schönheit keine haut um dem politisch 0
also ja vielleicht ein oder zwei szenen
halbherzig ich finde es spannend ich
meine wenn man sich mit dieser fische
affäre auseinandersetzt die polizisten
die wollen tatsächlich sehr tollpatschig
und es ist zum teil sehr absurd was die
für überwachungs berichte geschrieben
haben um die situationen die sie
überwacht haben
diese waren gegen den vermeintlichen
kommunismus und st ich meine die waren
alle es war eine eine doofe sache aber
wenn man es dann nur alsdorf und plumpe
in einem film darstellt dann bringt es
wie nicht viel und ich denke man hat
auch aus deutschland mit der stasi
affäre das leben der anderen gemacht
dann so hoch dramatischen man hat
gesehen was das bei den menschen
ausmacht von ihren ängsten mitmenschen
überwacht zu werden wie das leben
vernichtet hat und so weiter und hier
ist es wie einfach nur die gelegenheit
damit die frau die kaffeetasse vom tisch
und vor allem mein mann sieht wie sie
die kaffeetasse auf dem tisch stellten
dann kann man wie die stoppuhr und
setzen wie lange dauert es bis sie dann
die diese tasse vom tisch aber das gibt
ja es gibt ja eigentlich wenn es eben
solche sachen die gebaut sind in diesem
film der das ist ja auch für das
drehbuch das beste drehbuch nominiert
also nicht alle dienste hat das
geschrieben mit linie braucht man baba
sommer zusammen also da funktioniert
offensichtlich vieles also dass diese
strenge gut aufgenommen werden und diese
geschichten eben aus komödie wird sehr
erzählt werden ich glaube der größte
fehler den viele begeht ist dass er die
liebesgeschichte ins zentrum setzt weil
die funktioniert überhaupt nicht
ich habe da überhaupt ja ich habe beim
zweiten mal schauen habe ich darauf
geachtet wo ist der funke der jetzt
verliebt sie sich der passiert nie und
man hört einfach muss
die gefühle brannten auf 30 ha ha jetzt
haben sie sich verliebt aber es ist
völlig unplausibel
man muss aber dazu sagen dass zum
beispiel moritz leuenberger den film
sehr geschätzt hat und er war immerhin
leiter der druck der parlamentarischen
untersuchungskommission geblieben ist
ist dass er gesagt hat diesem thema kann
man nur mit einer komödie bei kommen und
das tut der film ich möchte noch auf
eine szene die wir uns noch anschauen
wollen und das ist eine szene treffpunkt
réthy finden sie ganz super oder gut tut
oder oder wegweisend für den film wie er
hätte sein sondern genau es ist
wir dürfen diese szene zeigen wie haben
sie vom verleih bekommen man darf nicht
vergessen denn was jetzt anschauen ist
wie gesagt das jahr 1989 in berlin fällt
die mauer und wir hatten die erste
abstimmung über eine schweiz ohne armee
und die lebende schauspielerin die sich
dieser polizist verliebt die hat gerade
an diesem anlass das lied weckte der
hochschule gesungen und zwar vor den
zunft brüdern ihres vaters und jetzt
will eben diese odin noch etwas sagen es
ist es soldaten in eigene patrick soll
da ich weiß also was es bedeutet und ich
weiß auch dass eskaliert die zisch für
den für die mutigen manöver militär
gerade heute wo der ist so direkt
angriffen
ich frage mich wirklich was ist ihr lied
überlegen was sind das für gestalte wo
ernsthaft takt schweizer lesen sind das
überhaupt schweizer der sich als obmann
der räuber der schlüssel direkt werden
die hard rock
ob schafe heißt schweiz abschaffen
[Applaus]
darin sind anne paß moskau 10
die rollen eigentlich doch nur schon
suchbegriffs geld für was helmut schöns
fußballstadion
das wäre doch eine gute note um das
ganze pack mal für sein
und was war die männer vom arbeitsplatz
abholen und packe die ganze bahn die
mitsamt ihren familien wenn sie mich
fragen demokratie ich habe mich für gut
die ziethe und braucht ein starker
führer eine woche ruft eine frau
bereitet kandra kriegs macht eine wo das
land über eine riesige passe ob man
steine fertig sein
die ganz spezifisch das ein schock wieso
geht mir denen nur das was du dir mama
papa blattmann war und die volksbanken
russland ist sowieso papa papa ja und
nicht zuletzt sollten ein für allemal
die so genannten künstlern erledigen
oder bindet
die viel aufmerksamkeit
schönen abend also sehr lachen nicht
ich habe gern wütend ich bin ich finde
das ist die einzige szene im film wo ich
wirklich wo ich dabei war weil ich finde
wenn der ganze film so wäre dass man die
durch das übertreiben etwas sichtbar
macht das sonst unter der oberfläche
bleibt dann wäre es gut es ist auch
ungemütlich ihr zuzuhören es gibt so bis
zu einem gewissen punkt findet man so ja
okay kann sie sagen und dann irgendwann
nein
und dann will tatsächlich irgendjemand
noch applaudieren so dieses nicht dass
ein großer genau dass wenn das so wäre
wie diese szene dann werde wirklich
großartig finde die szene ist auch
großartig gespielt wie rammstein hat
auch gesagt dass sie also diese szene
gelesen hat gewusst hat sie will diesen
film machen und das spürt man sie hat
lust diese szene zu drehen und sie macht
das ganz toll sagt die schauspielerin
wie sie vorher das ist ihr bett lied
gesungen hat es mich weniger überzeugt
das haben wir jetzt nicht klappt haben
wir nicht gesehen
nein ich finde dass das allerschlimmste
daran für mich ist dass sie damit diese
herren gruppe auch rehabilitiert oder
weil sie sagt alles was ganz viele leute
damals und heute noch wirklich denken
und am schluss wird doch nicht
absolviert das heißt die sind doch nicht
so schlimm wie sie es ihnen vorwirft und
das ist für mich fatal das ist genau
entweder hat er für und das so gewollt
aber ein versöhnlicher firmen machen
über die fischen affäre und über die die
militärpolitik und waffen
verkaufspolitik der schweiz was für mich
bei herrn wäre oder den machern
macherinnen ist das gar nicht bewusst
dass das ihnen passiert ist dadurch dass
sie die szene ist war ja hätten sie
klatschen sollen oder was
dem hat was aber ich glaube das liegt
daran dass man diese moralische
botschaft vermitteln wir mit dem film
auch am ende als er diese diese
ansprache auf der bühne noch hält und
nochmal alles erklärt was er jetzt
eigentlich hätte lernen können oder was
ich tatsächlich gelernt hat und was der
film eigentlich aus geschichte uns hätte
erteilen müssen fasst er da noch mal
zusammen diese moralischen predigt und
auch das hier gebe ich dir recht ist so
ein schwachpunkt innerhalb der besten
szene also für mich jetzt ist kein
tiefgang es ist sehr französisch sagt
man sehr oder ist es nicht doch billig
ist es nicht wirklich eine parodie ist
es sehr einfach eins zu eins ich mein
wenn der film rauskommt wird gibt wird
es sicher leute geben die diese szene
ausschnitten das wird dann die nächsten
20 jahre auf youtube herumgeistern in
rechten kreisen messing und rechten
kreisen drinks ja wenn man das aus dem
kontext rausschneiden könnte zum -
führen gut abgesehen also soweit die
rechnung kreisen überhaupt diese firma
spekulationen dass miriam stein übrigens
nominiert als beste schauspielerin
chancen glaube ich hat gut also man muss
vielleicht sehen wer sonst noch so
sabine timoteo ist nominiert während tun
das ist starker konkurrenz überzeugen
wir werden es erfahren morgen wissen wir
wer gewonnen hat und auch eben moskau
einfach als bester film und drehbuch
schauen was dafür preise bekommen
wir lassen das man mit den nominierten
spielfilmen und wir kommen zu dem
dokfilm respektive alle filme über die
wir sprechen hier und auch die wir
zeigen und die nominiert sind alle sind
von einheiten der seg gefördert worden
und mehr zu den filmen finden sie also
kritiken porträts und
hintergrundberichte finden sie auf
unserer website und wir gehen jetzt zu
den nominierten filmen und da sind die 5
den kindern eine stimme geben
es sind mini ältere ich will mit ihnen
wie entscheidet fische ich hasse bald
where we belong scheidungskinder
berichten über ihr leben mit 1 2 oder
vielen eltern insel der stille will um
so mit der pflege traumatisierter vögel
das eigene trauma überwinden
[Musik]
mhh weitgereiste onkel african wenn der
weiße europäer weißen europäern das
schwarze afrika erklärt sie leben
glücklich in den tag hinein kümmern sich
um keinen lebensstandard wissen nichts
von produktion und rendite
liebeserklärung an die uhr
der bürgerliche mann der männer liebt
und seine unkonventionelle großmutter
[Musik]
bedingungslose liebe immer und ewig wie
ein ehemann mit seiner chronisch kranken
frau durch europa reist das also die
nominierten dokumentarfilme und über
zwei wollen wir etwas ausführlicher
sprechen und zwar zwei filme die in je
drei kategorien nominiert sind beide
sind filme die tabuisierte themen auf
die leinwand bringen ganz genau
hinschauen beide filme sind von
erfahrenen regisseurin beide filme waren
auch oder beide regisseurin waren auch
schon mal früher mit filmen beim
schweizer filmpreis dabei dass eine
jacqueline zünd die andere
fanny bräuning sie hat den schweizer
filmpreis sogar schon einmal gewonnen
fangen wir also an mit fanny bräuning
neuen dokumentarfilm immer und ewig es
ist eine art roadmovie über ihre eltern
die mutter schwerstbehindert wir haben
es gerade gesehen der vater immer dicht
und ihre seite immer mit ihr dabei der
film feierte letztes jahr in solothurn
an den filmtagen seine große premiere
gewann da auch den prix de soleure den
jurypreis was sie grob berg sie haben
damals diese welt premiere moderiert ich
stelle mir vor dass war sehr emotional
ja das oracle wechselbad der gefühle ich
habe den film vorher vorbereitet ich
habe ihn allein geschafft und viel
geweint habe mich selbst ein bisschen
überrascht dabei weil ich nicht immer so
ich versuche dass er professionell zu
machen aber der film hat mich sehr
betroffen positiven sind im kino oder
nichts
zu tun gab es auch viele momente wo das
publikum auch gelacht hat und der vater
von fanny bräuning hat nachher gesagt
dass das ihn überrascht habe er dass das
dass man das auch lustig finden könnte
auch leute die ihn nicht kennen oder die
diese familie nicht kennen und von dem
her war sehr gelungen sehr emotionalen
in vieler hinsicht firmen über
behinderte menschen sind oft
problematisch aus verschiedenen gründen
aber dieser film hat mich sehr überzeugt
ich denke die fanny hat in dieser
intimen geschichte die richtige
gratwanderung runden wir sprechen gleich
ausführlich in dieser runde über den
film aber schauen zuerst rein in den
film von fanny bräuning immer und ewig
die eltern sie sind on the road mit
ihren wohnwagen niki und anne brüning
und ihre art miteinander umzugehen
[Musik]
das sagt ich war da bin ich konnte so
löffler
man kann die logik schafft ob ich vor
mir nicht vorstellen dass du nicht den
anderen beiden rama lama gemacht aber
das mache ich ja sehr wichtig
ich hatte keine und sag ich weiß nicht
ob du so
es ist so
den muss ich machen himmel
[Musik]
das ist aber so
also nicht ein film über die eltern von
fanny bräuning sondern auch ein film wie
die tochter eben die welche syrien die
fanny bräuning zu ihren eltern steht
also sie bringt sich da massiv selber
einen diesen vielen fußgruppen machten
sie stellt fragen aus dem off sie redet
zum teil getrennt mit dem vater und dann
auch mit der mutter dann bekommt es auch
eine art hieß es ist also die zwei
perspektive auf diese beziehungen auf
den umgang mit der krankheit der mutter
ja sie stellt auch fragen die zum teil
unbequem sind aber die älteren gehen
dann gut drauf und sie ist auch mit der
kamera sehr nahe aber nicht immer selber
und der karmann gmbh mediaroute kamera
arbeit geleistet es dafür auch nominiert
aber man vergisst dass die kamera da ist
weil man ist einfach ganz nahe an diesen
menschen dran und der film ist auch sehr
fotogen irgendwie die eltern sind beide
auch sehr kamera affin und das wird
alles einfach nach und nach erzählt
damit man immer mehr versteht was die
mutter auf einem fluss geschichte erlebt
hat sie war für künstlerin und fanny
geht dann immer wieder auch in die
kindheit in die jugend ihre mutter auch
in ihre eigene kindheit sie zeigt was
die mutter für für kreative
schaffensphase hatte und und da versteht
man nach und nach auch noch mehr was ist
was diese frau ausmacht und auf was sie
alles verzichten was zählen peters sie
haben gesagt es ist hängen geblieben
also der film war ja vor einem jahr in
den kinos und hat die preise gewonnen
es hängen geblieben ja absolut und vor
allem weil fanny bräuning ihre eltern
überhaupt nicht idealisiert das war ja
naheliegend gewesen bei so einem thema
das man zum beispiel den vater
idealisiert der seine karriere als
fotograf aufgibt und jetzt nur noch
seine frau pflegt sondern er zeigt sie
mit all ihren stärken und schwächen auch
es gibt eine szene da bürstet er ihre
haare und das ist ja fast schon
übergriffig und man denkt oh nein will
ich das wirklich sehen und das ist zeigt
die beziehung nicht im besten licht dann
gibt es andere szenen die sind sehr
lustig vielleicht muss man wenn man das
hier
nicht gesehen hat kurz ein bisschen
ausruhen um zu erklären was ist denn
wenn die kann das lustig sein
da erzählt zum beispiel fanny bräuning
dass sie angst gehabt hat dass sich ihre
eltern scheiden lassen weil sie sich
immer so heftig gestritten hätten und
die mutter sie kann sich gar nicht mehr
dran erinnern und sagt was wirklich das
ist ja toll toll dass wir uns gestritten
haben und fanny bräuning versteht gar
nicht wieso das toll sein soll aber sie
findet ja wir waren so vital damals
fantasten dann haben wir uns gelebt in
dieser beziehung lebten in dem buch sie
haben mir gesagt solche filme machen sie
wie das hat einerseits persönliche
gründe
je nachdem was man schon erlebt hat in
seinem leben und andererseits ich habe
ich noch nie verstanden warum man solche
tagebuch filme macht die sich wie lange
ich gar nicht hinsehen dieses gefühl
habe ich da die ganze zeit weil ich
finde das geht mich nichts an
ich habe das gefühl die personen die man
sieht mit denen wird etwas gemacht dass
sie vielleicht gar nicht möchten
es ist wie wenn ich in einem fotoalbum
von fremden blättern würde geht mich
nichts an und ich werde zur wahren
gemacht was ich nicht möchte
also es ist zu intim wir haben und ich
sage nicht in gewinnen darin jemanden
beim leiden zu sehen
es ist etwas anderes wenn diesmal das
leiden das für mich ich konnte nicht
richtig sehen weil ich es einfach ich
ertrage es nicht
für mich war es eine zurschaustellung
das des leidens und das ich habe kein
verständnis
ich sehe das anders habe ich habe
vielleicht auch nicht die gleichen
persönlichen bezüge für mich war
lebensbejahend und perspektiven eben das
ist auch das problem dass es oft wird
das behauptet in firmen über behinderte
menschen hier hat es mich doch überzeugt
auch weil die mutter
man hat sind dem ausland nicht so
gesehen aber sie kommt wirklich zu wort
sie hat zwar körperlich schwierigkeiten
mit einem sprechen aber sie ist sie
seien eine tafel frage und sie kann sich
ausstrecken und sie kann sich
verständlich machen und das dass sie aus
ihrer perspektive erzählt macht es für
mich anders aus filme wo man quasi
bevormundend über behinderte menschen
spricht
aber warum muss die regisseurin sich
dann trotzdem selbst auch noch in den
film hinein setzen wenn sie wenn sie die
älteren zeigen würde dann auch für mich
ist das essenziell sind sie muss auch
dabei sein sie muss haltung zeigen sie
muss ihre eigenen reaktionen auch klar
machen alles andere wäre für mich war
juristisch gewesen und sie sagte sogar
dass sie sich manchmal ausgeschlossen
gefühlt hat von ihren eltern weil die so
ihr ding haben diesen diesen kit und der
nici also ihr vater erzählt ja auch ja
wer weiß denn ob sie nicht abgehauen
wäre wenn das nicht gehabt hätte können
genau machst du mich ist dass sie wissen
wer diese geschichte erzählt und dass
die auch beteiligt ist und dass sie aus
ihrer perspektive auch ihre kindliche
sicht auf ihre eltern im film auch wie
weiterentwickelt und auch sie reibt sich
für mich ist es nicht nur juristische
expedition ist ischen dem sind sondern
sehr mutig dass sie bereit ist oder dass
alle bereit sind ihre sehr intime
lebensgeschichte auch zu teilen damit
andere menschen etwas davon haben aber
sind sie zu bereit ich habe das gefühl
man spürt die ganze zeit und wieder
schon des vaters er weicht aus ergibt
nicht richtige antworten gibt floskeln
von sich man hatte also ich hatte die
ganze zeit das gefühl eigentlich ist es
ihm unangenehm
eigentlich möchte diese kamera gar nicht
da haben es geht ihm zu weit
ich habe einen ganz anderen eindruck ich
glaube er hat genossen endlich einmal zu
wort kommen zu dürfen er hat auch aus
der firmen kino gekommen ist ein sehr
sehr vielen interviews und diskussionen
teilgenommen es war immer auch ein
anliegen dass menschen auch in unseren
diskussionen zu tun gesagt dass mehr
bewusstsein gibt in der öffentlichkeit
für altautos challenges von behinderten
menschen ich denke hat diese gelegenheit
sehr genossen
er hätte aber auch hat fanny bräuning
auch mal gesagt wahrscheinlich er selber
einen anderen film gemacht also hier
hätte die geschichte natürlich auch dass
er zeit vergehen die herzen auch
künstler sie uns dann ist es schwierig
ich möchte diese diskussion sehr
spannend da beenden ich denke bei den
chancen vielleicht für den gewinn des
besten dokumentarfilm wenn man da schaut
fanny bräuning hat no more smoke signals
gemacht das war vor zehn jahren
der elf jahren kam der film als damals
hat sie auch den prix de sóller gewonnen
und anschließend den schweizer filmpreis
also die chancen stehen sehr gut dass
der gewinn könnte ja er wurde jetzt auch
dreifach nominiert genauso ein wie
belohnt und very long ist mir was für
den kopf und das ist mir das herz
und ich glaube das herz gewinnt gut dann
kommen wir jetzt zu where we belong und
schauen uns diesen zweiten firma an den
wir besprechen möchten where we belong
wohin wir gehören übersetzte das ist der
film von jacqueline zünd sie lässt in
ihrem dokumentarfilm kinder zu wort
kommen die über die trennung der eltern
sprechen und ihre neue situation
für mich auf jeden fall ich schlimm wenn
man frau entscheidet sich mama und papa
denn manchmal so hallo schön blöd so
vage spinnens mini ältere ich will
irgendwie entscheidet fische ich hasse
beiden hauptsache fest
zusammen können wir nicht weit und halt
unbedingt welle
und es hat sehr manipuliert der tat
immer so seit erreichte ernste und also
krank und gemüse scheiße wo unsere
mutter erzählt waage unsere mutter sie
nicht fähig von luft wasser kann mir zu
mir
vielmehr wird alles besser auf dem motto
schlacht
[Musik]
zerstört eine das macht eine fertig wenn
denn bei die ältere teil besuchte
stacheln damen sind somit vier versteht
man das nicht und dem goldman auf das
unternehmen wieder an die ältere teil
zerbricht in dem sinn wenn er vernichtet
damit unklar
der verstoß nicht und es schadet das
auch so da kann ich doch beide linie wie
so was ich jetzt eigentlich los dass
zwei von fünf kindern die zu wort kommen
im dok film where we belong dann ist
buche ein solcher film der steht und
fällt mit den protagonistinnen
protagonisten und die kinder die ich auf
den zimt da ausgewählt hat die sind
schon über zurück ich sehe ja also auch
die anderen die man jetzt nicht gesehen
hat man kann sie alle wirklich ungefähr
in die gleiche die gleiche waagschale
legen es ist unglaublich beeindruckend
wie die über ihre situation reflektiert
und ich hab ich wusste gar nicht dass
kinder
ich habe keine kinder aber ich war mal
lehrerin ich wusste gar nicht dass
kinder so so weise über das leben
nachdenken können schon in so jungen
alters hat mich unglaublich beeindruckt
das hat auch noch zwei zwillingspaare
zwillingsmädchen die noch ein bisschen
jünger sind diese tolle aussagen auch
und ich finde es ist auch ein film über
resilienz also über die widerstandskraft
dieser kinder
es ist kein film der sagt scheidung ist
das schlimmste der welt und wir zeigen
jetzt ein paar kinder die besonders
darunter leiden überhaupt nicht ja es
ist mir so
sie wurden da hinein geworfen was machen
wir jetzt hier verzweifeln nicht wir
machen jetzt einfach etwas gras und beim
beim bluter bei ihrem der macht er wie
am ende so eine bezieht ist ein fazit
für sich wenn das alles nicht gewesen
wäre dann wäre mein leben jetzt nicht so
man ein teil meiner entwicklung würde
fehlen
und das sagt zwar ein kind ich fand dass
unglaublich er verzeiht oder sie
verzeihen ihren eltern
sie geben ihnen ratschläge sie sind
reifer als die erwachsenen das ist
und sehr faszinierend man hört dass uns
nie kinder sind manövrieren auch selber
ins um trennungen geht aber ist das ist
die eine ebene diese inhaltliche was wir
erfahren dieses diese statements der
kinder
das andere ist natürlich gerade bei
jacqueline zünd der regisseurin die sehr
formal arbeitet was punkt ziemlich
funktioniert das in ihren augen also
dieses ist wirklich designte schon fast
inszenierte ja wenn man ihre filme kennt
kennt man das auch was wäre und clyde
nobody das ist jetzt wie quasi der
dritte film in einer trilogie fast von
wo sie sehr universelle große themen
herunterbricht anhand von einigen
wenigen gut ausgewählten protagonisten
und protagonistinnen die kamera ist
anfällig sehr schön sehr gelungen aus
technischer sicht aber ich habe mich bei
dem film gefragt ob dieser stil wirklich
passt zum thema und jetzt um vielleicht
ein bisschen brücke zu schlagen zum
vorherigen film ich hätte es hier nicht
schlecht gefunden man hätte sie als
regisseurin mehr im film gespürt dass
diese gespräche mit den kindern die
wirklich alle sehr groß artig sind diese
wird zum teil ein bisschen inszeniert
oder ein bisschen gesetzt
ich hätte mir gewünscht dass sie
manchmal vielleicht aus dem auf etwas
kapital ihrer motivation soja oder
einfach das essen ging es weiter im
hätte aber gelang geht das hätte
abgelenkt von den kindern und ich finde
dass es kühl obwohl das thema ja sehr
emotional ist aber die optik ist kühl
aber ich finde das passt dann auch
wieder zu der isolation zu der
einsamkeit die diese kinder alle erlebt
haben also insofern finde ich schon dass
die ästhetische umsetzung und der inhalt
zueinander passen ja aber für mich wird
es dann ein bisschen weniger authentisch
zum teil also es hat eine hohe
künstlichkeit die kinder reden ja auch
direkt in die kamera
das sieht man ja auch nicht also da
werden dokumentarische settings werden
absolut vermieden es hat eine hohe
kunstfertigkeit und eine hohe
künstlichkeit beides ist eine reduktion
auch als eben es kommen nur nur die
kinder von nicht die enten und sieht die
ab und zu mal irgendwo vielleicht die
leisten ein bisschen was man aber sehr
viel sieht was sie ausmacht das sind
nicht die ganze zeit diese talking heads
diese sprechen den köpfen sondern sie
zeigt auch sehr viele poetische szenen
aus dem auto
die zwillingsmädchen am strand in den
ferien oder der bauernjunge unterwegs
mit seinem tüv und solchen sachen und
ich habe mich danach gefragt bei diesen
szenen sie sind sehr schön sie sind sie
ja sie haben seine ausstrahlung aber
sind das wirklich sachen die sie aus dem
leben der kinder rausgenommen hat nimmt
oder ist es mehr ihre perspektive wie
sie sich vorstellt dass outox leben
dieser kinder und vielleicht in
anlehnung an ihre eigene
kindheitserinnerungen ja dass das da hab
ich ja das ist sie sich sicher gewählt
da zusammen mit den kindern also sie
thematisiert dass sie sagt sie möchte
gerne dieses gefühl dass du hast möchte
sie auf die leinwand bringen
damit dann sucht sie nach bildern die
das einfach zusammen mit aber das weißt
du was cool sein das größer das weiß was
sie aussagen mit ihr aber der film gibt
und keine hinweise es ist so dass
entstanden ist und ich bin dann eher ein
fan vom interaktiven wo der film sich
selber ein bisschen vorstellt und wo man
ein bisschen so hinter blick hinter den
kulissen aber ihr als geschmackssache
ich denke das ist nicht dass es keine
ablehnung vom film sondern einfach mehr
sei eine reine geschmacksfrage
man könnte eine diskussion draus machen
ob das jetzt noch einen dokfilm sei oder
nicht
was wäre wenn nicht habe ich mich
gefragt was ich mir ich habe jetzt
zweimal gesehen
ob es eher ein es sei wäre vielleicht
also ich bin dann immer mehr doch viel
mehr so wie dieser film also eher sehr
modern absolut und das formal makellos
würde ich sagen ist ein film der von
vielen festivals läuft der natürlich
wunderbar damit eigentliche einladung
bekommt rund um die welt funktioniert
indem sie ihnen auch so aber nicht
konnte blieb hat nur 200.000 ein dritter
gemacht ja also das ist ein widerspruch
in den beraterinnen greifen die musik
fand ich auch kein gewinn für den film
der es auch für beste musik nominiert
ich fand die musik auch eine spur zu
penetrant dass man die kinder sind so
stark und so wie sie sich ausdrücken von
ihren gefühlen ja die ganze
emotionalität ist schon da und diese
penetrante music school war für mich wie
ja fast überflüssig
das hat mich nicht gestört gut also
chancen für den filmpreis
ja aber nur in den technischen
disziplinen in den technischen also das
feld sehr stark für die rückführung
dieses jahr wieder einmal
ja wir sind gespannt genau
herzlichen dank für diese diskussion
diese einschätzungen morgen wissen wir
mehr dann ist bucher mexiko bergseen
petersen
bereits morgen wissen wir wer einen
schweizer filmpreis gewinnt das bug gibt
die preisträger morgen in einem
communiqué bekommt die große gala die
preisverleihung die welt wie gesagt
dieses jahr aus aber wir sehen uns
trotzdem am nächsten freitag abend auf
sf zwei dann gibt es nämlich unsere
spezial sendung mit den gewinnerinnen
und gewinnern der schweizer filmpreise
und mit einigen überraschungen dazu wir
feiern zusammen mit unseren kolleginnen
von rts und er sieht den schweizer film
und zwar dreisprachig bund und
hoffentlich auch leidenschaftlicher und
sie sie natürlich ganz herzlich
eingeladen zu dieser exklusiven
filmpreis party im fernsehen wie gesagt
am freitag abend auf sf zwei bis dann
bleiben sie gesund
[Musik]